hello everybody good afternoon my name
is nicko Sawyer I'm a partnerships
manager in the play apps team based here
in Berlin and it's a great great
pleasure to have all of you here today
for a while now
I've been really focusing on the topic
of subscriptions and it's actually
pretty amazing to see how far the
subscription business on Google Play has
come and how well it has developed since
we got together for playtime last time
in 2016 so about one year ago we have
actually on boarded over 3,200 new
subscription services to Google Play
half of them which are completely new
apps with the other half coming from
existing apps with stock which started
offering subscriptions this includes
developers such as Vkontakte from Russia
Mike Khanna from France flightradar24
from Sweden or even supercells game boom
Beach to just name a few so clearly
subscriptions are having a great
momentum and proofing points your being
here we're having a more more full house
and if you attended any of our events
before playtime Google i/o or an
industry specific event event you should
be pretty familiar with the our
subscriptions offering so for today we
don't want to bore you with the basics
we don't want to bore an expert audience
with kind of repeating this stuff over
and over again instead we will share
insights on how you can take your
subscriptions business to the next level
so we will talk about how you can
outsmart subscriptions as every business
grows it starts it starts facing its own
challenges so when it comes to
subscription businesses we're from you
about such things as declining payments
from users the difficulty of figuring
out the right balance between features
and price points or churning subscribers
and the issues of winning them
so for today's session we took ten of
the most common challenges we hear from
you the developers we work with on a day
to day basis and we structured them in
three buckets the buckets that make up
your subscriptions revenue so for the
next 15 to 20 minutes we will share some
solutions to help you outsmart them
let's start with the tricky top of the
funnel acquisition on conversion a first
challenge we hear is that developers
don't know where the subscribes are
coming from which markets which channels
or which devices and therefore they are
unable to optimize the value proposition
unless performing markets double down in
the highest converting markets or
targeting more lucrative devices so over
the last few months we've launched
several subscription specific reports in
the Google Play console to allow you to
easily deep dive into all of that the
user acquisition report in the Play
console allow you to understand the
markets that drive the highest install
and subscriptions which acquisition
channels are most effective in driving
subscriptions for you
how your subs are performing along the
whole funnel and very importantly also
how you're performing against your peers
so all of that is extremely useful
information for you to optimize your
subscription acquisition strategy
challenge number two we often hear from
developers is that not enough users
perceive the value of becoming a
subscriber so we have two solutions we
want to suggest for that first is to
make sure you promote your value
proposition at various touch points
within the app and especially during the
onboarding health and fitness up fuel
ethic
freeletics redesigned the onboarding to
emphasize the value proposition which is
getting a user really
fits rather than the apps features and
this increased conversion by 10% for
them language learning app memorize
prompts upsell opportunities based on
user activity so what that means is they
detect what is the best moment to
highlight premium features for example
somebody keeps tapping on the audio
button to replay a spoken words that
that then triggers an upsell prompt to
highlight audio mode which is a
subscription only feature and they have
pop-ups linked to specific enter their
similar pop-ups linked to specific
interactions on screen so once they
detect a user is doing a certain
activity in the app they triggers the
apps the upsell so very intuitive and
very natural to the user to then go to a
subscription another solution is a
pretty common one it's offering a free
trial to get users to try before they
before they buy our user study shows
that 78% of subscribe subscribers start
with a free experience
oh and as we announced in the keynote
you have asked us for shorter free trial
periods and we have listened so now you
can offer three day free trials instead
of the minimum of seven which we had
before so this could be really relevant
for businesses with high marginal costs
challenge number three we hear from
developers is about users abandoning the
purchase flow and unless this is the
first time you're attending any of our
events or speaking to anybody of us from
the team you would probably have heard
our recommendations before implement
Google Play billing implement Google
Play willing to offer you users multiple
payment options across over 130
countries globally and a trusted
reliable and frictionless 2-step
checkout process and beyond that
starting January 1st 2018 we're updating
orchards
and fee for subscribers who are retained
for more than 12 paying month to 15% to
recognize developers who maintain
long-standing subscribers and create
great user experiences challenge number
challenge number four is related to have
users hanging around in the free tier
without ever making a payment a good
solution for that would be to use
introductory pricing to offer periodic
sales to users who pet which is a super
popular cooking up in Japan ran a 50%
discount during Ramadan and lets you a
4.5 X increase daily subscriptions
versus a comparable period in fact we're
seeing many success many successes with
introductory pricing and many of the
developers we speak to now consider it a
key marketing tool now let's move on to
the next bucket of challenges those
related to retention and recovery and to
me personally it's another great sign
that we get more and more questions
about this because it also means that
your business has grown so much that
this is actually a major point of
questions and feedback we get from you
so starting with the challenge we hear
from almost every developer in some
shape or form trouble of retaining
subscribers it is really something
everybody talks about and everybody
tries to optimize and that is very
straightforward right
because improving retention rate is so
crucial to the bottom line of a
subscription business and therefore we
want to offer two solutions you can use
to optimize your retention rate overall
the first solution is to give users
something to nurture by gamifying the
user experience and I completely
appreciate that when I mentioned
gamification the buzzword alerts going
the risk of the buzzword
is really high so let's add so let's go
through some best practices to add some
color what we mean by that first it's
important that you measure your users
engagement versus the engagement
objectives that you have defines seconds
you want to make sure to surface this to
the user and allow the user to actually
show it off for example in the profile
another way to think about it is to
incorporate in up rewards or real
savings for users hitting engagement
milestones and then you can D
incentivise subscription churn by making
valuable rewards available for
subscribers only language learning app
duolingo successfully incorporates many
of these mechanics into the app so if
you want to get some inspiration
download the app and check it out and
see what they do also its pier memorize
which I've mentioned before offers
discounts to users who hit certain
milestones so they're putting the last
as the last best practice I mentioned
rightly to practice again if you're
looking for some inspirations I
recommend you to check it out the second
solution to optimizing churn is more
straightforward it's to offer users
longer period plans and to present them
convincingly some tips on how to do that
first make sure your multi-frequency
plan is available that costs savings
versus the monthly plan second present
the equivalent monthly price to
highlight the cost savings so it's easy
for the user to compare and very
straightforward to see what they're
actually getting for committing for a
longer period three funnel all your
promotions as seasonal campaigns to
those longer period plans the Korean S
word platform watch her play diversified
from one option which was monthly to
four options one month three six and
twelve month and found that 40% of the
users
and actually choosing a multi-month
option so the next challenges that come
up come up when it's technically
technically too late it's too late
because your subscribers have churned
but the solutions we will show you are
probably the most requested as we've
heard from you over the last couple
months and probably a year
so the first churn challenge we usually
hear is that you have a hard time
figuring out why a subscriber has
churned as announced at Google i/o the
new churn reports in the Play console
give you visit visibility into the churn
reasons for example is a voluntary churn
involuntary churn or whether user has
also deleted the you app after canceling
but an either be even bigger challenge
we've heard from you is that you don't
know when your subscribers are churning
so we're really excited to present
real-time developer notifications as
koubek talked about already in the
keynote this morning it's our new
feature that immediately informs you of
any change in subscriber change that's
there any change in subscribe States
sorry so for example cancellations
suspension etc so you can act on it
immediately
so when subscribers have left and now
you can now that you can be notified in
real time you can actually craft your
win back message and we reach out to
churn subscribers to pitch the benefits
of your subscriptions again and to try
to win them back on gommi
a music streaming service in the Middle
East optimizes the in-depth messaging to
churn subscribers to reham ffice eyes
the premium features they are missing
out on for example here in the
screenshot you see the bring back your
38 hour
which is the subscription only feature
for ungawa users similarly brain
training app luminosity Lumosity
sense churns EULA's emails to notify
them about new content as a windbag
strategy and to close the whole windbag
loop we are now making restoring a
subscription much easier with a new
subscription restoration feature on
Google Play billing which we announced
this morning so to quickly recap these
last couple of challenges and solutions
combines this gives you a full
subscriber wind back solution the
subscriber cancels we send you the
developer a real-time notification about
that you the developer then send a
message to the churn subscriber and if
successful the subscriber can go back
and restore their subscription all of
that in Google Play billing pretty cool
huh
so we are constantly investing in
improving features related to windbag so
stay on the lookout on this topic while
all of that covered the voluntary
cancellation quite well what about the
users that didn't even want to cancel
but whose payments happen to get
declined because the credit card is
expired the transaction didn't go
through et cetera again we have two
solutions these two solutions can be
used separately or in combination the
first one is to enable grace periods if
you have an enabled grace period you can
basically go into your account in the
Google Play console and tick the box
right now by enabling grace periods in
the console you grant users an extra
three or seven days to fix payment
issues and at the aggregate level across
all developers we see that those who
activate grace periods see a 50%
improvement
in renewal decline recovery it is such a
simple but effective optimizations you
all can do basically now
and if you think granting a grace period
to user is not enough and the user may
need an additional motivation to update
the form of payments you can switch on
account hold to put subscribers in a
suspended state until they update their
form of payments see their notification
that Univision that Univision now pops
up to users whose payment has been
declined from there it directly deep
links into the form of payment update
flow in the play console in the Play
Store so whenever the user fixes their
for up for any payments on Google Play
the suspended subscriptions will be
reinstated immediately and as we
announced this morning this feature of
Google Play billing is now open to all
developers dating app tinder has been an
early tester and actually seen a 3x
increase in payment recovery since
implementing account holds so with all
these new and exciting solutions to our
smart retention challenges let's not
forget about pricing finding the right
price for any product is a science in
and in itself so no surprise we quite
often hear that you're wondering if
you're pricing correctly or if you're
actually leaving money on the table so
we want to run through three solutions
on how you can optimize that part first
you recommend that you test price points
with the help of firebase remote config
you can set up two or more Eska use
surface them to different user groups
and compare metrics to fit up find out
which performs better when doing that
please remember that the goal is to
maximize retention and not just the
signup so it may take a couple months
you to actually figure out which one
works better in that regard solution
number two is to offer multiple plans
with varying sets of features
entertainment apps CBS successfully does
cater to different audiences willingness
to pay with with two different plans one
way you get the content with limited
commercials and one where it's
completely at fear and both are a
different price points and then solution
number three is to use the plan upgrade
and downgrade feature of Google Play
billing to let subscribers seamlessly
move between the plans again
entertainment of CBS does this
successfully with their limited
commercials versus no commercial sell on
plans so every subscriber decides that a
price point of let's say $9.99 a month
is too much instead of having them churn
you give them the option to kind of
downgrades to $4.99 and obviously you
can do it vice versa and increase the
basket size and lifetime value so I
completely appreciate this has been a
lot of content in a short period of time
and it's an afternoon session however
let me quickly recap we presented one or
more solution to ten common subscription
challenges to our outsmart subscriptions
across the complete user flow as the
next step we of course want you to put
these solutions into action and to make
this as easy as possible for you we
actually summarized all of them in a hey
in a handy one shooter I think it's
actually two side two sheets but anyways
which you can download under this link I
give you twenty seconds to take a
picture and because sometimes we like to
kick it old-school we also have a
printed out version which you can pick
up at the front and we're gonna have
laying out later so you can take it back
to your team's put it up in your office
and start getting busy with implementing
these solutions
that's it for me I really hope the
session was useful thank you very much
for paying attention
you